en este vídeo veremos la teoría del
orbital molecular para una reacción de
ti el saler entre dos moléculas de ciclo
penta bien o el ciclo penta bien o es
muy parecido al 13 butadieno lo que
haremos será entender cómo la teoría del
orbital molecular predice que el
producto endo es el producto en mayor
cantidad
aquí tenemos nuestras dos moléculas de
ciclo penta bien o digamos que la
molécula de arriba representa a nuestro
bien
y la molécula de abajo representa a
nuestro 10 no filo
sabemos que se formará un enlace entre
el carbono 1 en el 10 y el carbono 2 en
el lleno filo
también se formará un enlace entre el
carbono 4 en el hielo y el carbono 1 en
el 10 no filo solo he puesto esos
números pero no tienen que hacer esos
exactamente entonces sabemos que en el
mecanismo para la reacción de ti el sal
de nuestro día no es relativamente rico
en electrones y nuestro 10 no filo es
relativamente pobre en electrones pero
también podemos pensar en el mecanismo
como densidad de electrónica que fluye
del bien o al bien o filo así que estos
electrones en rojo fluyen del día al día
no sólo estos serían los electrones en
rojo y los electrones en azul se moverán
desde aquí para formar este enlace
finalmente los electrones en rosa
formarán
en la cep y así que tenemos un
movimiento de 6 electrones pi para un
mecanismo concertado en la reacción de
piel al de si el hielo y el 10mo filo se
acercan de esta manera estos hidrógenos
nos quedan hacia afuera y al extender la
molécula los hidrógenos quedarán arriba
con respecto al plano y el anillo
quedará hacia abajo ya que estos enlaces
y estos están hacia abajo este sería
nuestro producto endo y es el producto
favorecido así que obtuvimos biciclo
penta de lleno a partir de dos moléculas
de ciclo penta de lleno ahora veamos
esto con orbitales moleculares aquí del
lado izquierdo he dibujado los orbitales
frontera para el lleno
estos dos orbitales corresponden al 10 y
del lado derecho
estos orbitales corresponden al bien o
filo
notarán que los orbitales son
exactamente iguales porque en este caso
nuestro bien y bien o filo son la misma
molécula lo cual simplifica las cosas
ahora si la densidad electrónica fluye
del bien o al bien o filo eso quiere
decir que la densidad electrónica se
tiene que mover desde el orbital como
del lleno es decir el orbital ocupado de
más alta energía al orbital más bajo del
10 nov y lo que sería el orbital plomo y
podemos dibujar algunas imágenes que
representen el orbital como el humo del
hielo y el lleno filo digamos que el 10
no es la molécula de arriba
y el 10 no filo es la molécula de abajo
vamos a colorear las fases si observamos
el orbital omo del día que sería este de
aquí
si empezamos con el carbono 1 podemos
ver que en el orbital como la fase azul
está arriba
y ahí está y lo mismo tenemos en el
carbono 2 muy bien en el carbono 3 y 4
la fase azul se encuentra abajo vamos a
colorear las
y en el caso de la fase en rojo podemos
ver que en los carbonos 1 y 2 se
encuentra abajo
y en los carbonos 3 y 4 se encuentra
arriba
este sería nuestro diagrama para el
orbital o modelo ahora vamos a
representar el orbital lumo para el bien
o filo que sería este de aquí esto
representa a nuestro orbital lumo en el
10 no filo como podemos ver en el
carbono 1 la fase azul se encuentra
arriba
y ahí está en el carbono 2 se encuentra
abajo
en el carbono 3 se encuentra abajo y en
el carbono 4 la fase azul se encuentra
arriba ahora para la fase en rojo en el
carbono 1 se encuentra abajo
en el carbono 2 arriba
en el carbono 3 arriba y en el carbono 4
abajo
muy bien entonces cuando nuestro día no
y nuestro 10 no filo se acercan tenemos
dos planos que se acercan entre sí y
podemos ver que la fase del carbono
cuatro en nuestro bien y la del carbono
1 en el 10 no filo coinciden así que
podemos hacer un traslape constructivo
de fase es decir formar un enlace y lo
mismo ocurre entre el carbono 1 en el 10
y el carbono 2 en el 10 no filo al ser
fases simétricas se pueden formar
enlaces si colorea mos los enlaces en
esta molécula este sería nuestro enlace
rojo
y este sería nuestro enlace azul
entonces la simetría de las fases
permite que se den traslapes
constructivos a estos enlaces que hemos
formado con los orbitales moleculares se
les conoce como la frontera de
interacción orbital molecular primaria
entonces esta es la frontera de
y como podemos ver fue un acercamiento
en do ya que el producto en do es
favorecido pues en este producto ocurre
una frontera de interacción orbital
molecular secundaria en esta parte
déjenme colorear las fases
este sería el carbono 2 entonces esto es
azul
este sería el carbono 3 así que tenemos
azul abajo
y luego tendríamos la fase rojo arriba
y luego pase rojo abajo por aquí
tendríamos rojo arriba
y rojo abajo
entonces nos queda azul abajo
y azul arriba
muy bien observen que estas fases en
azul se pueden tras la par y lo mismo
ocurre con estas fases en rojo así que
tenemos una interacción adicional y se
conoce como la frontera de interacción
orbital molecular secundaria entonces
esta interacción nos da una estabilidad
extra cuando tenemos el producto endo y
por eso es el producto favorecido pero
echemos un vistazo al producto exo aquí
tenemos el producto exo nuevamente
tenemos la formación de enlaces esta vez
entre este carbono y este y otro por acá
nuevamente sigamos a los electrones
digamos que estos electrones pi en rojo
se convierten en estos electrones y
estos electrones en azul se convierten
en estos electrones
finalmente los electrones en rosa se
convierten en estos y digamos que la
molécula de arriba corresponde a nuestro
bien
y la molécula de abajo corresponde a
nuestro de no filo
podemos ver que para este producto de
día el saler los hidrógenos se
encuentran hacia adentro y al extender
la molécula nos quedan hacia abajo esta
parte del anillo nos queda hacia arriba
y esta parte hacia abajo este es el
producto exo pero no es el producto
favorecido les explicaré por qué aquí
tenemos nuestro bien
y nuestro 10 no filo
vamos a colorear estas fases si
empezamos con el carbono uno en nuestro
bien o esta sería la fase en rojo en el
carbono 2 la fase en rojo también se
encuentra abajo
para el carbono 3 y 4 la fase en rojo se
encuentra arriba
entonces la fase azul será la opuesta
muy bien ahora en el orbital el humo de
nuestro 10 no filo en el carbono 1 la
fase de arriba es azul
y en el carbono 2 es la fase de abajo
también para el carbono 3 y en el
carbono 4 nos queda arriba y las fases
en rojo son las opuestas si analizamos
la situación podemos ver que las fases
en rojo podrían trasladarse entre el
carbono 1 del 10 y el carbono 3 en el 10
no filo y también tenemos un traslape
constructivo entre las fases de color
azul en estos carbonos entonces es
posible formar enlaces siempre que las
fases coincidan el producto exo es
posible pero observen que aquí no
tenemos una estabilidad extra ya que no
hay una frontera de interacción orbital
molecular secundaria como en el caso del
producto endo en donde si tenemos esa
estabilidad extra
entonces las fases deben coincidir para
que ocurra una reacción de 10 al des a
esto se le llama reacciones permitidas
por simetría